the new mortal kombat film is filled
with easter eggs both in what is shown
and what characters say here are the
lines in mortal kombat that have a
deeper meaning than first meets the eye
one of the central narrative arcs in
mortal kombat is the rivalry between
hanzo hisachi who becomes scorpion
and bihan also known as sub-zero the
film opens with bihan killing hanzo's
entire clan
family and then the man himself before
he does bihan
says
with this line the movie fast tracks the
backstory of scorpion and sub-zero's
clans and their long-simmering blood
feud
the shirai ryu clan itself is actually
an offshoot from sub-zeros called the
lin kuei which began when a member
defected and started amassing their own
followers
the lin kuei did not take this defection
lightly and made it their mission to
wipe the new shirairi u clan out of
existence
hence sub-zero's bloody mission
cole young the once successful mma
fighter who now can't win a match
is first approached about the mortal
kombat tournament by major jax bricks
after
an unsuccessful fight even though we
just saw cole take a pretty decisive
loss
jax refers to him as the man that took
the belt from eddie tobias
the line is delivered in a manner that
is clearly meant to make it seem like
eddie tobias is a formidable mma fighter
the fact that cole once robbed him of a
title means he was much more successful
in his younger years
but that's beside the point the name
itself is also meant to be a loving
reference to ed boon
and john tobias the developers credited
with creating the first mortal combat
game
another deep concept that gets a cursory
mention in the movie is that of elder
gods
when shang tsung is preparing to
assassinate the earth realm warriors
molina pushes back
by asking what of lord raiden if he
discovers we're breaking rules set in
stone by the elder gods the elder gods
are beings whose job is to ensure
balance among the many realms by using
non-interventionist methods
despite molina's fear of them
retaliating against shang tsung for
breaking the rules they've set the elder
gods themselves are not all-powerful
similar to the pantheon of greek deities
the elder gods are significantly more
human in the way they operate than
other interpretations of a divine and
omniscient being
the elder gods shinnok and setrion have
even been playable characters in the
game series
considering the amulet of shinnok
appeared as an easter egg moment in the
movie
we're curious to see how much of a role
the elder gods play in the film series
going forward
when the earthrealm warriors find
raiden's temple cole and kano are
quickly put on an intense training
regime
in order to build their skills and
unlock their arcana abilities
as kung lao begins to put the would-be
defenders of the realm through their
paces he says
all you can do now is test your might
that line is pretty straightforward in
the context of the movie but it's also a
sly reference to the first mortal combat
between fights players would
occasionally be tasked with competing in
a button-mashing mini-game called
test your might wherein their character
had to punch through blocks of wood and
other strong materials to score points
the nonchalant callback in the 2021
movie seems like an easter egg left
specifically for players whose love of
the games goes all the way back to the
first
although lou kang has been featured as
the protagonist for many of the games
and movies in the mortal kombat universe
he plays more of a supporting role in
the 2021 film
he still gets the opportunity to shine
some light on his backstory though
while speaking with cole between
training sessions he reveals unlike
kung lao i was just a worthless straight
for reasons beyond my ken
master bori cho found me half dead in a
gutter and brought me to the wushi
academy
like many of the franchises characters
lu kang's backstory got fleshed out
considerably as the series went on
i die at the coliseum you on a rooftop
fighting lord raiden
our future lukang it is insane
the 2002 game mortal kombat deadly
alliance introduced the character
beau rideshow the outworld martial arts
grandmaster who turned his back on his
home realm to train earthrealm warriors
like liu kang
and kung lao borichow's status as an
outworlder on the side of earthrealm
makes him a significant character in the
general lore of the games especially
considering liu kang secured
several earth realm victories in the
mortal kombat tournaments
while many characters in the mortal
kombat series have fascinating histories
and storylines there are only a handful
that have real significance to the
broader arc of the story the 2021 film
smartly brings in several that are less
important as fatality fodder one of
those being cabal
in the movie cabal is introduced as an
assassin working for shang tsung
and an associate of kanos he even says
of his old frenemy
he's the reason i live in an iron lung
cabal's distinct mask
and breathing apparatus have been a
hallmark of his characters since he was
first introduced in mortal kombat 3.
however while the movie implies that
kano caused the injuries that put cabal
in his iron lung in the games the story
is a bit different
in 2009's mortal kombat a reboot that
retells the story of the first three
games cabal is a police officer who
sustains grievous injuries during
outworld's invasion of earthrealm he's
found by kano who fits him with his
respirator that allows him to breathe
despite the damage to his lungs so
in the games kano quite literally puts
cabal in his iron lung but
only to save his life although raiden's
warriors feel outmatched by shang
tsung's collection of assassins
the former ends up pretty much wiping
the floor with the latter that doesn't
seem to bother shang tsung too much
though
shortly before the credits roll he
announces today you have killed my
warriors and you think you have won
but death is only another portal the
immortal combat games have featured
several narrative arcs wherein
previously slain characters rise from
the dead
in mortal kombat 3 shang tsung helps
resurrect sindel the wife of outworld
emperor xiao khan
similarly the 10th installment of the
series saw multiple dead characters
return as mind-controlled versions of
their former selves
known as revenants the evil sorcerer
also menaces the earthrealm warriors
with a warning
next time i see you i will not bring
fighters i will bring armies
while the first two games tell stories
that are relatively contained to the
tournaments
mortal kombat 3 features an all-out war
the plot of the game sees shao khan
enlisting shang tsung
to pull some trickery that ends with the
emperor invading earthrealm with armies
of outworld warriors
if or when the outworld invasion happens
in the films shang tsung's threat to
come back with armies is not
an idol one the original mortal kombat
had a relatively small roster of
characters
there were only seven playable fighters
and three special bosses included in the
game
all 10 of those characters made an
appearance in the 2021 film except for
one
the vain martial artist and movie star
johnny cage
cage doesn't make a physical appearance
in the first movie but based on the
ending fans will be seeing him if
there's a sequel
after defeating shang tsung's forces we
see cole in the locker room of the mma
arena when he's approached by his
fightbooker he declines the man's offer
to appear in a matchup saying that he's
off to hollywood the man replies
hollywood what the hell's in hollywood
fans of the series likely knew the
answer to that question as soon as it
was asked but to hammer home the
reference the camera lingers on a poster
for a movie starring johnny cage right
before the credits roll
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
mortal kombat are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you